to talk about that in more detail with
the government minister this morning in
the form of the environment secretary
george eustis mr eustis thanks for
joining us on the program you're a
farmer uh what difference have you seen
in rising costs
well the big impact on the farming
industry has really been the impact on
fertiliser costs and so there's always
been a very close correlation between
food prices internationally global
agricultural commodity prices and the
price of gas and oil and that's because
there's huge amounts of gas that goes
into manufacture fertilizers and so it
has a knock-on impact
so farmers have actually seen the cost
of their fertilizers treble in some
cases quadruple that's a really big
increase in their costs it's also led to
increased feed costs and that's why
that's starting to come through
the system now as some retail price
inflation what does that mean for us
when we go to the supermarket
well the um the better news is that we
have quite a very very competitive
retail market um you know with 10 big
supermarkets and the four main ones
competing very aggressively particularly
on some of the um you know the lower
cost uh everyday value items for
households so things like spaghetti and
ambient products there's a lot of
competition to keep those prices down
where it gets harder is on things like
chicken and poultry and some fresh
produce where those increased feed costs
do end up getting passed through the
system because these people work on
wafer thin margins and they have to pass
that cost through so what's your advice
to people then who want a sunday roast
with a chicken for the family but they
can't afford it
well the um the thing to bear in mind is
that if you look at household spending
on food in the uk it's actually you know
the lowest in europe partly because
we've got that very competitive market
it used to be for the poorest 20 of
households about 16
of their income used to go on food that
dropped a few years ago to about 14
percent it's going to rise again now but
generally speaking you know what people
find is that by going for some of the
sort of value brands rather than uh you
know own branded uh products they can
actually sort of contain and manage
their household budget but it will
undoubtedly put a pressure on household
budgets and of course it comes on top of
those high gas prices as well so if it
costs less than a fifth of the average
um household budget are people
why are people telling us they have to
choose between heating and eating
the the reality is that the the price of
food and in and of itself doesn't
necessarily cause
uh poverty but obviously what does is if
you've got very sharp rises in people's
energy costs if it costs much more to
put petrol in the tank if they've got
housing costs going up all of this adds
to household pressures and of course you
know inability to buy food or struggling
to afford food is the first thing that
people notice because it's something
they need on a daily basis and have to
buy on a daily or weekly basis so it's
noticed first and that's why you know we
recognize that it's why we've increased
the national
living wage it's why we've made some
changes to benefits it's why we've
introduced
some of those rebates to try and help
people with their energy costs all of
which will help people through what is
undoubtedly a challenging time isn't it
more chicken and egg to go back to what
you were saying a few moments ago in
that people can't afford to put fuel in
their vehicle and if they do have to do
that in order to go to work then they
don't have enough money to buy food for
the kids at the weekends
well there's a cumulative impact to
inflation on households
budgets of course yes the government
does acknowledge that
rishi sunak absolutely acknowledged that
in his spring statement it's why
you know he made some changes to the the
planned national insurance so that uh
fewer people on low incomes would be
paying that increase uh it's why we've
got the the 150 pounds council tax
rebate to give people immediate uh
relief on their household budgets it's
why there's going to be a further 200
pounds rebate on energy coming later in
the year so there's a package of
measures we've put in place uh none of
it completely mitigates uh the impact
but all of it's designed to try and help
people through a challenging period and
it's also why a 77 year old woman
pensioner has to ride a bus all day to
keep warm because she can't afford to
heat the house
well look in addition to all the other
things that we're doing we've also got
uh we've increased the funding in the
household
support fund that's given to local
authorities we've got an extra where is
it obviously well why are you riding on
a bus
exactly well i i feel if it was your
mother well in that particular case and
i i really um you know would advise uh
the woman in question to seek support
from her um from her um local authority
they they've been given now these these
household support funds specifically to
help those who fall between the cracks
so we've increased the national living
wage which helps people that are working
we've changed uh some of the taper rate
on universal credit to help people are
on benefits how would you feel if it was
your mother who was riding around on a
bus all day because she couldn't afford
to stay warm at home well um if it were
my mother then i would um support her
and go to the local authority and try to
get access to that house it's a family's
fault
well no but what i'm saying is i'm if
you're you're asking me what my advice
to her is and my advice to her would be
to go to the local authority and try to
get some support from that household
support fund it's what it's there for we
doubled the fund to a billion pounds
it's there to support exactly cases like
elsa's when uh the prime minister was
asked about this uh yesterday he said oh
yeah well i introduced a freedom pass so
she won't have to pay for her travel on
the bus he actually didn't introduce the
freedom pass why would he say that
well look um the prime minister he gave
his interview i i'm not a um aware
precisely what he what he said he said
that he introduced a freedom pass on the
bosses and he didn't why would he say it
um well i i don't know i and he'll know
better than than any of us what he might
have done when he was uh london mayor
and some of the the measures that he did
absolutely speak a lot doesn't he well
uh i think the point here if you're
coming back to the original you know the
original question you had uh what would
my advice be to elsa well my advice to
it would be you know not to to to stay
on on a bus all day to try and stay warm
my advice would be to seek some support
you know from the local authority and um
that's got a they've got a fund
specifically to help cases like here's a
thought why don't the government look at
a windfall tax um and then they will
have
an extra oh i don't know several billion
two billion or thereabouts in fact even
more than that to play with well if
you're talking about on on oil companies
they they already pay
a higher rate of corporation tax in
other companies around 10 percent higher
uh corporation tax if you look at bp
they publish good results yesterday but
they will pay around a billion pounds in
tax
on their north sea oil revenues well
they've also announced 18 billion
investment and what we do need to see
from these companies given that we still
have north sea oil we need to see them
investing in that so that they'll
continue to do that in fact the chief
exec uh bernard looney said he would
continue to do that even if there was a
windfall tax
well all i would say is we've already
got a higher rate of tax for those
companies in north sea oil it's already
they pay enough tax well it's a
corporation tax it's already 10 percent
higher um we judge that's the right
thing at the moment we don't want to
deter investment um in the north sea uh
they're a big employer um bp um for
instance already saying it wouldn't
deter them but they would they would
continue to invest even if there was a
windfall tax george osborne did it so
why would you not do it do you feel
they're paying off taxes i'm sure you
know richie sunak will look at these
things and keep all of these things
under review and you know he was asked
about that this week and he said that's
exactly what he will do you know but for
now we judge uh yes it's right that
these oil companies pay more and they
already do pay more the headline rate of
uh of of income tax or corporation tax
is already 10 percent higher overall
with all the other levies and taxes are
in place they pay double the tax that
most companies would pay um you know if
at some point um there's a case for
reviewing that well obviously you know
rishi has got um budgets and autumn
statements or a budget coming up in the
autumn another statement coming after
that he obviously keeps the entire tax
regime under review all the time do you
feel that bp pays enough tax as of today
well as of today i understand it's going
to pay about a billion pounds in tax
well well oil companies if you're asking
me oil companies overall are paying
twice as much tax on their revenues my
question is do you think they pay enough
tax well for now yes and that's why
we've chosen not to do it because they
already pay a higher tax okay even
though they say that if there was a
windfall tax they would continue to
invest in the same um what the projected
investment would be they would continue
with that in the united kingdom in the
north sea uh oil fields etc um and we
have seen previous governments do it
previous conservative governments
including george osborne and even going
back to the 1980s margaret thatcher
introduced a windfall tax when she felt
that banks were making too much profit
on interest rates
it seems like a slam dunk
well you know all i say i'll come back
to what i've said they pay higher tax
already a higher headline uh rate of uh
of corporation tax bp will pay a billion
pounds in tax on those um north sea
revenues you say that they would like to
be taxed more i mean of course
well they would be willing to pay more
taxes they wouldn't affect their
investment decisions but you know rishi
sunak when he makes these decisions has
got to be thinking about the sector as a
whole and what one company might say may
not apply to others and what we do need
is to see these companies
investing in the north sea so that we
don't become dependent on other
countries for our oil and gas it's
important we've got that
gas and oil is going to play an
important role during our transition to
net zero particularly with the
importance of hydrogen power and things
like that so we have to be able to have
that investment during this period
underlying profits for bp more than
doubled to 6.2
billion dollars in the first three
months of this year i'll say those
figures again more than doubled to 6.2
billion dollars in the first three
months of this year and yet in 21st
century britain we've got pensioners
riding around on a bus to keep warm
well my understanding that is a global
um profit figure and if you look at the
the north sea figure it is lower than
that but they are going to pay a billion
pounds in corporation tax on that north
sea
yes i know and our view and you know the
view that rishi sun has taken the moment
is they're already paying more tax
increasing that tax rate might uh deter
investment and also uh introducing a
winful tax may not actually raise a huge
amount of extra money and you these are
always difficult balance judgments why
then if that's the case why did uh why
did george osborne think it was a good
idea and why did even margaret thatcher
think it was a good idea well it was a
different era and a different time and
um we actually do have higher rates of
tax on oil companies at the moment
sounds like you've ruled it out
well nothing's ever uh obviously uh
ruled out um the tax system's kept under
constant review we have two
um you know key fiscal events a year the
uh the autumn budget and the statement
are you let's talk about the local
elections are you worried about um sinn
fein being on the brink of victory in
northern ireland
well look um these are democratic
elections we've got a a very clear
approach uh in northern ireland under
the belfast good friday agreement where
you have our power sharing um so whoever
the largest party will be there must be
a power sharing executive that's how
things are established in northern
ireland and obviously what we want to do
and it's for the people of northern
ireland to decide who their
representatives are what the makeup of
that is but it's very important that
whatever's decided respects both
communities uh that's always been the
case it's an absolutely critical
component of the good friday agreement
and we're really committed to trying to
make that northern ireland protocol work
better to improve the way that's
interpreted
to get an agreement with the european
union to ensure that the goods can flow
and that some of the you know rather
ludicrous things that we see like them
banning the sale of seed potatoes and so
forth which makes no sense at all that
we can actually remove that okay i
suppose i'm taking you back uh to the
fact that if shin fein win the local
elections in northern ireland they want
a border referendum if there's a border
referendum then it is likely that we
will see um an island of ireland united
which would mean that this prime
minister potentially
was the prime minister in charge of
overseeing the split up of the union and
then who knows what might happen in
scotland
well look um let's take one thing at a
time i think from from the reports that
i've seen uh in all that and you can't
tell let's wait and see first of all
what happens uh on thursday but i think
it's also the case that quite a lot of
people are trying to acknowledge that's
a possibility well it's a possibility
obviously that shin plane will be it's a
it's a democratic election and then
obviously a border referendum um and
then you don't know what would happen uh
they want to board a referendum don't
they say that you'd be heading down it
that direction a lot of people are
referring to what might happen well a
lot of the people i think in the
northern ireland election this time
you know are not um you know voting uh
for once through the through the prism
of um either uh you know being
nationalists or unionists i understand
that people although that's the way that
they're really this government think
about
well look we will we will deal with
whatever um we're faced with after we
have the um the results on thursday so
what is the government position on the
reunification of ireland
well northern ireland is part of the
united
uh kingdom we're committed to
democratically they choose to be part of
after a border referendum they they then
decide to be part of a united island
then what's the position because you
said it would be a democratic election
democratically in democratic elections
um but but whether or not it's not such
a far-fetched from whatever
whether or not
whether or not to have a uh a referendum
is always a matter for the uk government
always has been
we foreign gone into that we will wait
and see
what happens when we have that uh uh
election uh on on thursday as i said
many uh people in many communities
northern ireland are not so it's
democratic till it's not they're not
voting this way necessarily
on the basis of whether people are
nationalist
or whether they're unionists sometimes
they're voting for a local candidate you
can't read too much into that election
result based on the parties that are
there and whichever party comes out as
the largest party
you know the power sharing executive
will carry on as it has done previously
fascinating debate unfortunately we're
out of time so i'm going to have to let
you go i'm actually going to ireland on
friday to uh chap on the late late show
and i know they'll ask me about this
which is why i was pressing you this
morning thank you very much